yeah welcome to this video but some of
some pop-up was irritating me okay I
judge must have photon is that my car
cruel off okay um yup hi Katilyn giving
the usual check it's a bit unusual this
move order but I think it's a playable
option why it is somewhat better here
but it's not it's not the end of the
world
interesting is out for e from you
possibly than ever on may be here and
then 95 yeah black blacks ideas always
too I'm basically to say okay my
structure is very solid I've got a good
Bishop there on c8 and okay you've got
more space but I don't have any
weaknesses is it really that that big of
a deal hmm that's as somewhat weird move
okay yes but I was thinking that this
isn't that big of a deal right I mean we
just have a couple of trades now can
take these three first right doesn't
really matter i can also do this ever
would have been interesting okay it's
Regev three a move i think it is a move
preventing f4 that's important if he
doesn't get an F for he's got absolutely
nothing okay now we have some trades
going here or i can go queen f6 actually
that's nothing not no not even not be
five as a move so I can do that good
good idea I think
okay hmm that's interesting ice Knight
is really wrong there on d3 I think the
simple thing is just take on d3 play
Knights if I this is just giving me an
equal game but I think I can do this how
why not being a little bit more
ambitious
even don't laugh this is really tempting
me to do that that it leads to at least
equality if I take on d3 i'm just not
quite clear if i have something better
he is threatening neither for those this
is important so okay I'm doing this it's
a simple thing to do yet here i think
it's equal we can take and play look the
one that should be equal yep it's g5g
for set an idea that's probably
unnecessarily unnecessarily weakening
now okay we've got an equal position
it's it's okay
draw authored the I did offer i draw but
he wants to continue I don't think he
can do much I mean he's pretty much tied
to that age born
yeah it seems that he's got some
ambitions to lose the game don't quite
get it see what is he doing here for
looking one or whatever this this this
maybe this this takes cheek skin g3
there how many can you see them can we
maybe can draw but not quite sure why
he's doing that check
maybe you can draw after the rook trade
but at the end i have man ok we will
seem so King g5 King edge three h5 txtx
into three King III king you five King
23 and I'll be 59 k can you can just
about draw maybe I can get be five and
maybe I should've climbed modified first
then I should apply p5 first ah no it's
a draw that's a shame he did everything
to try to lose the game never Arthur the
last I was very lucky that draw for him
I just I just I have to play be fired
first instead of age 5 and then he's
just using as he deserves to because
that was completely completely weird
said of just taking the draw there he
killed himself by this is weird maneuver
and now aged 5 now I'm winning this and
so I've just a little bit too late yeah
I'm just picking out this to him yeah it
was just an equal end game until she
played played this this this is just
yeah just suicidal yeah I mean okay
booga Sri maybe still draws but this is
just suicide yeah and I just be 5 ends
over or now be fine I saw it too late
aside too late hit one minute little
stupid dad was very equal Bishop 83 is a
bit of a strange idea but oh actually at
this one I didn't think of that this is
a strategically very weird move but it
just picks up a pawn
yeah bishop see 894 oops so Bishop a
tree was not just strategically strange
but also technically bad before I this
is I mean completely harmless but it's I
don't really have anything here there's
still about equal may be here I can be a
bit more vicious but mom it is equal I
mean it should have been a draw but then
he killed himself but i didn't i didn't
take that offer unfortunately okay well
thanks for watching